i hear lots and lots of firefly rumors
but this one seems to have a bit of
weight behind it
welcome to sidetrek your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
so firefly is one of my favorite tv
shows um i'm actually being
off for a few days from work and the
first thing i did was pretty much watch
firefly
i then got some news from people i speak
to that work in and around mgm they know
people in and around disney and
apparently there have been some serious
conversations about firefly returning
and even some early negotiations but
what are those negotiations well
basically disney plus are very
interested in returning firefly
since their acquisition of fox
firefly ended up on disney plus and it
is actually done very very well they've
got very good numbers for a tv show that
only ran for 14 episodes
nearly 20 years ago
and they got cancelled because no bugger
watched it first time around
disney loved basically that they're
getting really good viewing numbers for
something they've had to put no effort
into but what is the news and who are
the negotiations with
well it's this is going to be very early
stages there is no sort of plot design
there is no script there's no nothing
disney are just exploring that if they
produce this series who is going to make
it
who will be the showrunner
well the one thing i can tell you
immediately is that it won't be joss
whedon joss whedon is not a particularly
popular person in the entertainment
business at the moment he has been quite
abusive towards many of the female stars
of his show and even some of the guys
and he is
a little bit of a pariah right now
also a couple of his big projects have
recently have not really succeeded i'm
looking at justice league there and even
though i personally thought that nevers
was a great tv show and i'm really
hoping it returns for a second series
joss whedon did leave that show halfway
through from his director and producing
role with very little news about why but
the rumor is it was again because of
accusations against the way he treats
some of the female stars
so disney are not looking to bring josh
sweden back but they are looking at the
people that produced the original show
and wondering if maybe some of them
could tim meniere was the executive
producer on the starting credits is his
name right up there with joss whedon and
negotiations have started very early
negotiations about him coming back as
the show runner he has apparently asked
for brett matthews to join him as
executive producer and co-showrunner and
to write many of the episodes going
forwards
this deal for me would be absolutely
stunning mainly because actually tim
menia wrote one of my favorite episodes
out of gas of the firefly series you
don't get many tv shows or movies that
you consider to be perfect
predator is a perfect movie die hard is
a perfect movie you know some of these
things this out of gas is a perfect
episode there is nothing about it that
is wrong
it's the perfect balance of humor drama
storytelling
you know we learned more about mal in
that episode and the other characters
um it had here it just had everything it
was it's literally the perfect episode
and tim bernier wrote it yes sir right
smart purchase this vessel
i tell you what
you buy this ship
treat her proper
she'll be with you for the rest of your
life
son
hey
son
[Music]
you hear a word i've been saying
after firefly he's gone on to produce an
executive producer and write lots of tv
he's currently the show runner for 9-1-1
and 9-1-1 lone star but 9-1-1 lone star
is just completed its third series and
there is no news on whether a fourth
series is going ahead so disney in early
discussions basically saying
if 911 lone star doesn't go ahead or if
we can make time in your schedule would
you consider this role for us would you
consider bringing back firefly now on a
streaming service this is probably going
to be a 10 episode run that seems to be
the norm nowadays so it's not as
all-encompassing as a big show that
takes six months to produce like 9-1-1
does this is something that tim minion
could do particularly if brett matthews
is there to support him now brett
matthews is mostly known for actually
his comic book work he's worked on
spider-man wolverine but he has actually
been executive producer of tv series
very successful tv series as well
including the supernatural he's
currently the executive producer and
writer for the series legacies which is
the spin-off from the vampire iris
but what would the show be well i have
heard rumors from the early stages of
the negotiations and what tim near is
basically coming and said he will not do
a hard reboot he will only do a
continuation story he's basically said
he wants to do firefly the next
generation
now it won't be based aboard a firefly
ship so the series will probably call
serenity now this will be a series based
within the universe that they created in
the original firefly series and the
serenity movie but it won't be based
aboard the firefly
now that is for two big reasons
tim near hopes that the firefight could
actually make a guest appearance
that we could get nathan fillion as mal
back in for at least one or two episodes
maybe the end of season finale or how
they kick the season off
now
apparently tim munir has already spoken
to nathan fillion about this and he
would love to do it
the only thing stopping him really is
schedule issues
but if it was just for the opening two
episodes it would probably only be a
week or two of filming it's something
that could be very easily done if
producers of the rookie allow him to
remembering that he's one of the
executive producers of the rookie so i
think he's going in there obviously we
wouldn't see wash or shepherd book
return but the rest of the characters
could we could also see wash and zoe's
child he would be 20 years old by now so
that would be a really interesting
sideline for this storyline as well
maybe that character is somebody that
could join this new crew
within the new show and it can actually
be washed and zoe's kid that we see in
the series as that nice little thread
through so guys get in the comments what
do you think about this news if these
early negotiations really are happening
and i got to admit underline it is only
a rumor
then what do you think that means for
the show i personally think these
conversations probably have happened i
think fireflies show they desperately
want to return and if they're going to
do it they would want to do it in a way
that maybe would appease fans because
look you know what people are like when
a new show gets announced like this they
immediately kick off and say it's not
going to have the same characters those
characters can't be replaced so it's no
point doing it personally i don't agree
people kicked off when the next
generation star trek was done because
they said it was peeing over the
original series and you can't have new
characters and they showed that you can
if done right this show could actually
be great because the universe that joss
whedon and tim minier created
is actually a very interesting one it's
quite a unique sci-fi universe it could
work really really well
it's just got to be done right disney
have to put in the money the effort and
the time to get it done right and tim
munir and brett matthews
for me they're the people to run this
and they could produce something great
let me know in the comments exactly what
you think though if you are new to the
channel please like subscribe hit that
bell notification really helps us out
also if you would like to become a fully
fledged side tracker and support the
channel please consider hitting that
join button
as always guys please stay safe i see
wow